the mountainous Trentino region of
northern italy is a stunning backdrop to
present a pioneering piece of automotive
design that Chizzy Talia 202 Grand Sport
from 1947 people have forgotten about
Piero do zo says our test driver
Christophe Bauer but in the 1920s he was
an international celebrity soccer player
racing driver Playboy and later
president of the Juventus soccer club in
1943 he founded cheese Italian cheese
Italia founder Piero do zo recruited
designer Dante J cosa from Fiat for his
new car brand the first model launched
in 1946 was a single seater race car
with a 1.1 litre engine borrowed from
the Zippy Fiat 1100 soon afterwards and
built on the same platform it was
followed by the first cheese Italia for
the open road the 202 available as a
convertible or coupe a
the engineering was actually from Fiat
explains Christophe a transmission
suspension engine all taken from the
good old Fiat 1100 they souped up the
engine a bit of course giving it 65
horsepower but by the late 1940s that
figure was less than impressive for a
sports car the cars aluminum body gave
it a total weight of just 600 kilograms
but that cheese Italia could have used
more engine capacity really get that
cheese Italia going Christophe advises
taking a maximum of momentum out of the
bends and with road-holding properties
like this that's not a problem but it
can't have been the only car able to
burn around the curves back then what
makes the cheese Italian so special it's
a light didn't lost via force it's hard
to imagine now the commotion the cheese
Italia car is dead its unveiling back in
1947 automotive design was still
essentially at pre-war levels a big hood
with wide fenders attached wide running
boards and flying headlamps and then
came this a single integrated package
these contours would prove defining for
subsequent generations of sports cars
the cheese Italia was otherwise a
no-frills affair it's flowing functional
form was a product of aerodynamic
insights from the world of Motorsports
designer of this masterpiece was
Battista Pininfarina he declared classic
forms to be outdated and that modern
cars needed gentle contours he put that
into practice here the cheese Italia is
both a design icon and a work of art the
Museum of Modern Art in New York made
the cheese Italia the first car ever to
be featured in an art exhibition in a
Countach state of this particular cheese
Italia model is also borrowed from a
museum Volkswagens site house words
presented alongside other automobile
milestones the cheezy Talia's marriage
of volume production engineering and a
sports car body inspired ferdinand
porsche jr. to build his four speedster
the Porsche 356 the simple elegance of
the cheesy Talley is also found on the
inside two instrument clusters a couple
of switches and levers why make things
complicated
old-school tunic doubled the output of
the four-cylinder Fiat engine a big
carburetor a sharper camshaft and
modified exhaust together helped put out
65 horsepower
cheese Italia was the first car maker in
the world to use a wind tunnel the
excellent aerodynamics helped push the
top speed up to 160 km/h the 202 Grand
Sport was the first cheesy Tony approved
for public roads until then the company
only made racing cars but the 202
benefited from that Motorsports
expertise fantastic aerodynamics and a
robust tube-frame chassis Sun dominate
the 1,100 CC division and the Mille
Miglia from 1947 to the early 1950s
despite under par engine performance the
Mille Miglia was considered the highest
profile car race of its time legendary
driver Tazio Nuvolari
nearly caused a sensation in 1947 when
he piloted his 202 Spyder into second
place
in 1947 ferry Porsche was recruited to
work on the three 6o together with
lutefisk ax
Robert Ava - Ava Horst and Carlos Habad
all talented designers in their own
right
their mission was to give the Grand Prix
competitor and add an edge a cheesy
tally of three six zero boasted
four-wheel drive a mid-engine and
supercharging it was likewise to be
piloted by Tazio Nuvolari
but the three 6o proved too costly to
support and never actually made it onto
the racetrack facing financial ruin
cheezy Talia's owner Piero do zio
emigrated to Argentina
his legacy survives in the form of the
202 Grand Sport driving the cheesy Talia
202 Grand Sport is not exactly an aha
moment and it's Christophe but looking
at it is its appeal is more that of a
sculpture than a vehicle of course it'd
be nice to own one and take care of it
every day
this was the blueprint of its era for
all future sports car generations and
certainly a milestone in automotive
history
you